hi girl Hi how are you so much it's so
great so good to see you too you're
looking like a million bucks oh thank
you
she is back y'all all right so Savage
Xfinity number four number four
your overall vision for the collection
for the show every well for the
collection
it's all about
self-expression and personal empowerment
and for me doing the show is always
about and has always been about
challenging the show before challenging
new ways of um
inclusivity yeah challenging new ways of
um talent and and finding talent and
even with our casting I always want to
bring new light to maybe things that
we've overlooked before
um so what kind of talent are you
bringing into the mix this time around
[Music]
maybe like an Emmy Award winner
maybe definitely definitely top models
Emmy Award winners
um we have Maxwell oh honey do you need
to say more is literally one of my
favorite performers but absolutely
excited to see him perform this year
yeah and you are always wowing I mean
truly it's the trailblazing event it is
a visual faced so how are you going to
wow us visually this time around I'm
hearing that you're even like kind of
blending reality unreal how are you
doing that right
well that's one of these surprises so I
can't really tell you girl you're always
one for surprise but you know we like to
challenge ourselves and challenge
tradition and find new ways of
redefining sexy and yeah it's fun you
know the Savage show is not really just
a fashion show it's an experience and
there's so many
uh aspects of entertainment all collided
into this one experience I feel like
you're always re-envisioning things
giving them and you know seeing things
the new light pregnancy was one of those
the last time I saw you you were
expecting now you are a mama so what Vic
congratulations
what is the best part about motherhood
right now Rihanna oh my God the
morning's just like seeing his morning
face yeah and you know like seeing a
baby with like little bags and waking up
and they're just like startled they're
trying to figure out where they at it's
the cutest it's my favorite part of the
day the mornings that's like I I cherish
that you're singing to the little one oh
yeah already oh my God the craziest
stuff like I've been making up just
freestyling making up that new lullaby
album right
you know I I literally said if anybody's
gonna ask your buddy album It's Gonna Be
You It's Gonna be Me I have to do that
and I'll get to that in just a second
but how little guy's doing great he's
amazing he's a happy baby that is
fantastic so next we've got Fenty volume
four here Savage xunty Vol 4. is it
gonna be Fenty kids next I know I
already asked you but now that you're a
mama I feel like I can really see it
come on nowry you know I always thought
doing kid stuff would be like
cliche and obviously the the obvious
thing to do when you have nothing cliche
when you have a baby right it's like the
obvious Next Step but
when I went shopping mm-hmm
that's what I realized like okay maybe I
need to start making the stuff that I
want my kids to wear because it's hard
it's hard I got my own like idea like
what give it to me tell me your vision
board she is about to just put it all up
my ideas girl
to bounce some ideas off of you honey so
since you don't want to talk to me about
those ideas with Fenty kids why don't
you talk to me about the Super Bowl
because we are so excited for this I
can't believe I even said yes but no but
wow you know like it was one of those
sorry it was one of those things that
like even when I announced it I thought
it was like okay I can't take it back
now it's like final yeah I can't believe
I just what did I just get myself into
because the Super Bowl is one of the
biggest stages in the world yeah it's an
Entertainer's dream to be on a stage
like that but it's nerve-wracking you
want to get it right you know
everybody's watching
and they're rooting for you yeah and I
want I want to get it right so what's
the challenge that I was willing to
accept well being a new mom nothing
would have gotten me out the house if it
wasn't a challenge like that and that is
the ultimate challenge for sure yeah I
was getting ready to say why was now the
right time to accept that happen well
now or never really yeah for sure for
sure
you get real comfortable being at home
as a mom
that challenging myself to do something
that I've never done before in my career
I have to live up to that challenge how
are you challenging yourself for this
halftime show and what do you bring into
the stage I can't tell you
something I know you get a little bit
you know what I want to incorporate
a lot of culture I want to incorporate
different aspects of
entertainment and things that I just
enjoy and bring it to the stage you know
what I want to celebrate the music that
I've made so I'm thinking your history
of home some of the folks that maybe
have helped you along the way well you
might have figured it you gotta figure
it out girl on my vision board I've got
ASAP I think you can hold it up let me
hear you real quick ASAP Jay Pharrell
Calvin Harris and Eminem all right but I
think so we need to replay this after
the Super Bowl and see how many she got
right